what is it that you think men want women
to know more about them I felt that for
women to understand what the male
experience is like we need to go back to
the lockdown of coronavirus that feeling
you get when you're walking around
lockdown right in the midst of the
chronovirus was how I feel like is to be
a man but people are afraid of you
people avoid you a feeling of unease and
unfriendliness and fear even like the
fact that your emotions are masked I
feel like it's such an interesting
reflection of the male experience that
feeling of unease and fear it's
frustrating how male and female
experience exists in opposite ends of
the Spectrum in a sense that men have so
few things nice said about them vast
majority of normal men never receive a
compliment and go weeks months years
about anything kind being said about
them but women have compliments shouted
at them from car windows like in the
streets cat cords but women have a
spotlight Society burning down on their
shoulders at all times especially if
you're an attractive young woman
whatever the differences are is not for
me to say but surely the answer is just
through talking about them we don't want
to go in a box we just want to be given
the chance to live our lives